[Música]
[Aplausos]
y más
[Música]
profesó es un señor me dijo joaquín
cuando me presenté en la clase de
robótica con un brazo mecánico
reemplazando al mío y me empezó a contar
muy entusiasmado la historia de un
hombre que tiene conectada una antena en
la cabeza que le permite ver colores
invisibles y que hasta se puede conectar
a wifi
si les pido a ustedes que piensen en
alguien mitad hombre mitad máquina
probablemente la primera imagen que se
les venga a la mente sea la de robocop o
la de terminator pero no la de neil
harbisson el muchacho de la antena es
por eso que me llamó tanto la atención
que me lo haya dicho un chico que tiene
7 años
a su edad mi relación con la tecnología
era completamente diferente a los 14
años a mí me fascinaban las guitarras y
como nunca fue una opción comprarla me
puse a fabricar una busque unos planos
en internet las herramientas que había
en mi casa y algunos muebles viejos a
los que le saqué las maderas también
agarré un imán varios metros de alambre
de cobre y unos tornillos con los que
hice el micrófono de mi guitarra
eléctrica y ese fue mi primer
acercamiento al mundo de la electrónica
pero hay algunas cosas que no las podía
hacer las tenía que comprar sí o sí como
las cuerdas y el clavijero así que junte
un poco de plata y me fui súper contento
a la fábrica de guitarras
ahí me atiende un hombre grande de voz
grave
y me hizo una pregunta que me puso muy
incómodo
pero para que guitarra nene
yo me puse colorado automáticamente
y a pesar de la vergüenza le dije que
era para una que estaba haciendo yo
me sostuvo la mirada por un segundo y
sin decir nada se fue al depósito
vuelve con las cosas en una bolsita y
cuando le estoy por pagar me dice algo
que no me puedo olvidar hasta el día de
hoy
no hace falta que me lo pagues cuando
termines la escuela venía a trabajar acá
quince años después puedo decir que ese
fue mi primer emprendimiento
donde en vez de ahora en vez de aplicar
en vez de usar muebles para destruir en
vez de usar muebles para construir
guitarras usamos tecnología como
inteligencia artificial y robótica para
generar un impacto positivo en la
sociedad y en el ambiente en el que
vivimos
decimos que una persona es un experto
dentro del área en la que se desarrolla
cuando logra dominar el arte de la
clasificación un médico por ejemplo
estudia y se entrena durante muchos años
para poder mirar una imagen y darnos un
diagnóstico
los romanos definieron el término datos
como algo que es entregado nosotros hoy
en día lo interpretamos como la entidad
más pequeña de información es un número
asociado a una variable que suelto no
tiene mucho significado
cuando empezamos a interconectar datos
es que podemos sacar conclusiones mucho
más interesantes la información son
datos y sus conexiones
y en el momento en que dentro de esos
datos y esa información descubrimos y
entendemos los patrones de
comportamiento que la rigen decimos que
llegamos al conocimiento y hoy las
computadoras vienen a simplificar nos
este proceso
supongamos que nuestro dato es un píxel
un número asociado a un color
si empezamos a interconectar píxeles
podemos sacar alguna información por
ejemplo en esta imagen que podemos decir
tenemos cuatro columnas cuatro filas dos
colores ocho tonalidades de cada color
pero en el momento en que ven la imagen
completa millones de píxeles llegan a
sus ojos un sensor que se llama retina
los convierte en impulsos eléctricos que
viajan por un cable que conocemos como
nervio óptico hasta llegar a su cerebro
y ahí es donde millones y millones de
conexiones neuronales les permiten decir
ah este es messi
eso que para nosotros resulta tan simple
para las computadoras no lo ha sido sino
hasta hace relativamente poco hoy un
software / un software un programa de
computadora entrenado con la información
entrenado con los datos adecuados no
solo que nos va a decir qué es messi
sino también que en esta imagen está
festejando el gol que le convirtió al
real madrid en el minuto 92 un 23 de
abril de 2017 y esto convierte la
computadora en una periodista deportiva
experta y esto es genial
salvo para los periodistas deportivos
porque porque la potencialidad de esta
tecnología es tan grande que está
revolucionando nuestros trabajos y
nuestras vidas sin que nos demos cuenta
quien tenga la habilidad de usar y
entender esta tecnología tiene infinitas
capacidades de desarrollo y los más
afectados en todo esto son los más
chicos que a su vez sienten una gran
atracción por la tecnología pero que es
nuestra responsabilidad decidir si lo
van a usar como una distracción en la
play en la tablet o en los celulares o
como inspiración para jugar a ser
ingenieros espaciales y construir
vehículos que puedan recorrer la
superficie de marte o científicos que
diseñen el modelo de una rana para ver
cómo va evolucionando su forma en
función del ambiente en el que vive y
por qué no también hacer un barco que
limpie el plástico de los océanos que
nosotros mismos les estamos dejando
cuando un chico descubre que puede
programar su propio videojuego que puede
hacer su propio videojuego pasan cosas
fantásticas la emoción y energía que hay
en esas clases hace que fluya el poder
de la imaginación y que los chicos se
puedan expresar en cada bloque de código
por eso es que es urgente que la
robótica y la programación se incorpore
en todos los niveles educativos para que
los chicos además de desarrollar
capacidades de pensamiento computacional
y del método científico adquieran la
capacidad de adaptarse al contexto tan
dinámico al que se van a enfrentar
y con esto no estoy queriendo decir que
mi deseo es un mundo lleno de
programadores mi deseo es un mundo con
personas que sepan usar la tecnología
para enfrentar a sus problemas y así
puedan elegir su propio camino muchas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]